you're watching the daily climate show
on sky news on today's programme
germany's cabinet agrees to cut carbon
emissions by an
extra 10 percent we speak to climate
activist louisa neubauer who forced the
new proposals
how cities around the world are and
aren't adapting to climate change
and why protecting peatlands could help
save the planet
[Music]
hello and welcome to the uk's only daily
climate news show where we track the
changes happening to our world right now
and meet those coming up with the
solutions and we aim to take you to the
heart of the climate crisis
explain the data driving the changes
that are already affecting us
but also show you just how far we've
come the german cabinet has approved
plans for ambitious new targets
to reduce carbon emissions it comes
after a landmark ruling from the
country's constitutional court
which found that current laws are
insufficient to protect
future generations one of the
environmental activists involved in the
case is louisa
neubauer she's one of the main
organisers of the
fridays for future school strikes
movement and is hugely influential in
the climate world
i spoke to her earlier and started by
asking if she's satisfied with the new
climate commitments from the german
government
this isn't about what satisfies me or
anyone else but this is about
governments aligning the climate
policies to the science and to paris
and the court in germany ruled that the
government needs to listen to the
science
and you know stick to the paris
agreement because it didn't do so in the
past and now
they did agree in fact on higher targets
but they're still in line with paris
so of course we're going to keep
fighting here well the changes that came
about in germany came about because you
went to court and you
won so is litigation the most effective
way
of making change rather than street
activism no i wouldn't
um i wouldn't put this in some kind of
hierarchy here
what we see is that we need to try
everything we can
and so i would rather understand this as
a huge puzzle and you know litigation is
one
piece of that puzzle and street action
and climate action civil disobedience
and working inside institutions that are
different puzzles and
you know ideally eventually they come up
together and they add up
and they produce that kind of pressure
and awareness that we so desperately
need
i mean i feel you know this this
litigation victory was huge
but we cannot solve the climate crisis
court case by court case
simply because you know these court um
systems worked very very slowly it took
over in a year for the court to decide
that the climate target that was decided
in 2019
isn't ambitious enough so i feel you
know we need to also understand that
these climate
cases litigation cases they can provide
a foundation for our work as
activists to then come back to that and
actually demand
our rights to be turned into politics as
well as the court case you've been
helping organize the school strikes in
germany
how did you first get started in that
what first motivated you to get involved
well you know i i never planned to
become a climate activist
simply because i thought that government
in the 21st century
would get things done and i mean the
science is there
and we see what the climate crisis does
today and i thought you know there were
people who were aware of all that and
would sort things out
you know by the end of the day and when
i found out a couple of years after the
paris agreement was signed
what was happening around the world and
also in germany her governments were
just failing so badly to stick what they
themselves committed
to do i got i got very irritated and
angry
and uh by i don't know by um coincidence
or so
i ended up at the climate conference in
poland in 2018
and i ran into greta tuneback and
apparently she was the only one who
acted like we were in a crisis
on this u.n climate conference and so i
went back home and was like okay i think
i
think
when you do something and i think i need
to do something
let's take a look now some of the day's
other climate news and the first major
offshore wind farm in the united states
has been given the go-ahead
the vineyard wind project will be
located 14 miles off the coast of
massachusetts
it's expected to create enough
electricity to power 400
000 homes in new england and create 3600
jobs
the project's application was cancelled
by donald trump last year
before being reinstated by president
biden after he took office
[Applause]
the eu will tighten regulations on air
pollution
waste and the use of chemicals it's all
part of a plan to protect
public health and address key causes of
biodiversity loss
the eu commission says it wants to cut
premature deaths associated with air
pollution by at least 55 percent
by 2030. and amazon has issued its first
sustainability bond to raise
funds in order to transition to more
environmentally responsible business
practices
the retailer wants to raise one billion
dollars to invest in renewable energy
clean transport greener buildings and
affordable housing
now one in four cities around the world
can't afford to protect themselves
against climate change
even though nearly all are facing
serious risks
the charity carbon disclosure project
received data from 812 cities on their
environmental plans and they found
that 93 of them are facing significant
climate impacts such as flooding
extreme heat and storms but there are
things that cities are doing
to tackle the climate crisis and make
themselves more resilient
so 20 percent have increased tree
planting or created
green spaces 18 have undertaken
flood mapping 15 are improving community
engagement and education
and 14 are developing crisis management
plans including warning and evacuation
systems
but more than half don't yet have a
climate action plan
that means they're more vulnerable to
the effects of climate change
well joining me now is monjour more shed
who's professor in sustainable
engineering at cardiff
university so what does this survey tell
us do you think about the level of
preparedness of the world cities
in the face of climate change
this is um we have known this for a long
time is that
although the science is out there
we know that the impacts of climate
change will be
will be felt but
cities have not prepared themselves
as such what kind of problems could they
face and what kind of steps
might they be able to take to build up
resilience
well as you have mentioned in there that
one of the key impacts the floods for
example
extreme heat a lot of cities
are heavily built up uh they're dense
and
not only because of the climate change
but because of the
uh the the the volume and the density of
buildings
the temperatures will be um you know
there will be
further increase in temperatures which
will have
further impacts uh you also have
uh impacts uh related to age and gender
so elderly and the infirm
and children will be more affected
you also have in some cities you also
have a significant level of uh
population growth in organization which
will also exercise the problem
um the the other uh
the other um at the other end of the
spectrum
you would see that the impacts are not
going to be
felt at the same time throughout the
year
so in some cities we
have seen predictions and projections
that
winters are going to be warmer
in other cities summers are going to be
warmer
so in a way the the impacts will be
differently felt and
is is not a one solution for
all and uh cities particularly in the
south
um have not been able to prepare
themselves
uh for climate change although some of
them are going to be disproportionately
affected by it
professor monjour more shed thanks very
much indeed
the government's introducing a new
scheme which will allow developers to
damage green spaces in one part of
england but then
pay to improve them in another
biodiversity offsetting is part of the
environment bill which was introduced in
the queen's speech
yesterday under the proposed plans
developers will have to
increase the variety of animals and
plants found on each development site
by 10 elsewhere the government hopes it
will allow
more development on green belt land
whilst improving
wildlife habitats gerald tub reports
the escrick park estate in north
yorkshire will be ready
if and when the environment bill is
passed to offset
biodiversity loss from private
development
there's absolutely masses of opportunity
the landowner here was chosen for a
natural
england pilot scheme as a biodiversity
compensation provider
it means that we will be able to
offer uh biodiversity
to what has been destroyed from
development plus an extra cent 10
which is going to be in embodied in the
environmental bill hopefully this year
so at least people who are living in new
housing estates or occupying new offices
will know that somewhere hopefully close
by there's a really flourishing
new wildlife habitat
but this development site near barnsley
shows the concept can cause anger
many local authorities are already
insisting on a biodiversity net gain
guidance on offsetting says to keep as
much within the footprint of the
development as possible
and this has been offset to a location
six miles away which is of no
interest or relevance to the people here
the government insists developers will
be incentivized
to keep wildlife habitats on site
or nearby but it also plans eventually
to allow biodiversity credits to be
bought and sold
on the open market biodiversity
offsetting is here to stay gerard tub
sky news north yorkshire
so the government's using an offsetting
system to improve biodiversity in
england but what other nature-based
solutions are out there
well scientists from the british
ecological society have examined how all
kinds of landscapes could be used
to combat the climate crisis they say we
need to get serious about peatlands
if we want to cut emissions so what's so
great
about pete
[Applause]
if the uk wants to get serious about its
carbon emissions it needs to get serious
about its peatlands
they are the most carbon dense
terrestrial store of carbon on the
planet
they're like giant ever expanding safety
vaults
underneath our feet but and there is a
problem
eighty percent have been damaged there
is
something that just about everyone in
the uk can do if you're a gardener
to stop using peat based composts
so every time you buy a bag you are
helping to destroy
an area of peatland then we can start
looking at how to restore them and that
restoration process
involves re-wetting them we need to then
start looking at the vegetation
that's growing on them and potentially
start to re-vegetate them
these peatlands can be our most
important way
of capturing some of the excess co2
that's in our atmosphere
so it's incredibly important that we
look after our peatlands
coming up on tomorrow's daily climate
show we'll be looking at what british
farmers need to do to help combat
climate change
you can catch that here on sky news at
the same time and on our social channels
and website
thanks for watching see you then
[Music]